you say cyrus et bien eu un coup de fil
pour les deux prochains épisodes
on va voir comment les anciens ont
essayé d'atteindre ce but ce but qui est
le plus naturel le plus instinctif et
peut-être même le plus partagé chez tous
les humains être heureux et pour ça on
va commencer par une pensée qui est
méconnu car l'image qu'on s'en fait
souvent en décalage par rapport à la
réalité c'est l'épicurisme une piqûre ce
qui est logique en fait parce que c'est
et picorer epicure c'est un philosophe
grec qui a donné son nom à une
philosophie qu'il enseigne notamment son
jardin le jardin des cultures et qu'il a
développée dans la lettre à ménécée 1
c'est une lettre dans laquelle ben cjd
au contraire ne mourrai pas mais né sait
déjà il faut savoir que les épicuriens
sont des atomistes android on imagine
plus d'atomes qui tombe
sauf que gong sont bri ont pas droit
parce que si on ne touchera jamais ils
ont un petit angle de chute qui
s'appelle clinamen et c'est grâce aux
clinamen qu il y adeux l'indéterminisme
et du hasard
dans cet univers composé d'atomes très
mal les mecs tu sortes ça alors qu'on
est quand même au ivème siècle avant
jésus-christ quoi genre à titre de
comparaison c'est bien avant windows 98
bref du coup le monde est régi par des
mécanismes atomique sauf qu'en fait tout
ce qui nous arrive
ça vient des atomes or à l'époque on
pensait que tout ce qui nous arrivait ça
venait des dieux de leur volonté
du coup bah ya plus aucune raison de
craindre les dieux mais dieu existe et
il faut leur bail
je crois encore ça et c'est pareil pour
la mort il faut pas d'accent non c'est
juste les atomes qui s'organise de
manière différente mais c'est un état
normal
et en plus tant que je suis belle la
mort n'est pas là une fois que la mort
est là ça que je ne suis plus donc en
vrai on rencontre jamais vraiment la
mort vous trouvez pas que la mort est
bien tout le temps au bon moment faux
porte pour les épicuriens le principal
obstacle du bonheur c'est la peur la
peur de la mort donc ce qu'on avait avec
le divertissement pascalien par exemple
et la peur des dieux or ça tombe bien on
vient de montrer qu'ils ne sont pas à
craindre
donc on vient de lever les principaux
obstacles du bonheur du coup on va
pouvoir aller le chercher
et pour ça on va faire ce que fait notre
corps naturellement c'est à dire que le
corps naturellement il suit le plaisir
et puis la douleur et moi n'a qu'à faire
pareil l'épicurisme est un hédonisme
c'est à dire une recherche des plaisirs
et un évitement des souffrances pour les
épicuriens c'est ça qui va nous mener au
but recherché qui est l'ataraxie
l'absence de troupes en gros une paix
intérieure et c'est avec cette recherche
du plaisir qu'il ya de gros contresens y
en a qui pensent que les piqûres isme
c'est une philosophie du kif et de la
décadence notamment à cause de ce
carpediem faut que la recherche des
plaisirs elle soit avant tout un homme a
déjà oublié
vas-y les halls olegario l'eau you do
you do you boulot non parce que tous les
plaisirs ne valent pas le coût certain
plaisir ont des peines qui les surfaces
ont par exemple temps soirée tu te prend
une cuite avec tes potes sur le coup
c'est cool on le lendemain souvent faits
graves normale et à linverse ta
certaines peines qui valent le coup par
rapport à ce qu'ils apportent derrière
par exemple une grosse séance de sport
sur le coup c'est difficile
ton corps ressent de la douleur mais
après tu as un vrai bien-être durable
allez on est choqué à l'étalon là c'est
important et ça fait mal schiele ça
suffit maintenant tu continue on va
finir par croire que tu es grecque
donc tout plaisir n'est pas à rechercher
et toute douleur n'est pas à éviter
il y à un calcul des plaisirs et c'est
dans cette même logique qui va proposer
une classification des désirs il y a
trois types de désir
les désirs naturel et nécessaire genre
boire et manger simplement les désirs
naturelle et non nécessaire c'est boire
et manger mais de manière un peu plus
sophistiquée ok mais avec modération et
les désirs non naturelle et non
nécessaire c'est-à-dire la gloire
l'amour de l'argent
donc ça c'est à éviter car ils trouvent
le ton âme en plus vu que les choses
auraient pu être différentes avec le
clinamen et ben j'aurais pu ne pas
exister et le premier kif
j'ai quand même du coup d'apprécier
pleinement mon existence je désire
[ __ ] j'aurais pu ne pas être là quoi
on peut noter aussi que c'est une
philosophie ouverte à tous ses terres
qu'il accueillait tout moment son jardin
que tu sois pauvre esclaves prostituées
ou même les trois en même temps alors
que ce n'était pas le cas d' aristote et
platon qui était avant lui j'espère que
les pics us mais maintenant plus car
pour vous n'hésitez pas à vous abonner
pour ne rater aucune vidéo moi je vous
laisse vous envoie du loch et de la fif